Let's talk about a particularly
provocative set of experience that
meredith chippers has done is this
fascinating Canadian researcher I've
spent so much time with,
so several years ago when I first got
interested in her work and I kind of
stumbled into her lab.
I was working on a different unrelated
project at the time when I stumbled into
her lab.
I've found her showing an array of
pornography,
so men with women,
women with women,
men alone,
women alone,
and even bonobos having sex to self
identified straight women,
gay women,
straight men,
gay men,
and measuring both their physical
response that is vaginal or response in
terms of erection for men and then
they're subjective response via keypad.
How turned on do I say I am?
And finding something fascinating which
was that wears male response was pretty
predictable.
The straight men actually did mostly
just get turned on to men with women or
women with women.
Gay Men equally predictable.
The women were very unpredictable and
kind of anarchic in at least their
physical response.
So again,
there was this big dichotomy.
The women were saying,
I'm turned on by what I quote should be
turned on by straight women,
by men with women or to a certain
degree,
I suppose men with men and gay women by
images of women,
et Cetera,
but their bodies were saying something
completely different and their bodies
were saying they were turned on by all
of it and perhaps most strikingly you
might think those bonobos having sex,
but at least you know,
reach something animalistic in men.
Know the men showed zero response
subjectively or physically,
but the women did show this physical
response to the image of Bonobos having
sex.
So a lot of interesting things about
this,
probably too many to name,
but one for sure is that the idea of
women's sexuality as somehow more
controlled needs to be put aside.
If we're going to do any serious
searching about arrows and women and to
this idea that women are somehow less
than visual,
less immediate in their sexuality than
men.
Again,
need to put that aside.
If we're going to do any serious looking
at truths about women's sexuality,
now here's a bit of later shivers
research that both goes along with but
also pulls us in a slightly different
direction than that original set of
studies.
So remember,
part of the original set of studies
shows women being quite a narcotic and
what they're drawn to.
She Evers decides,
okay,
let me take a set of straight women self
declared straight women and show them
just for types of photographs and see
what happens for types of pornographic
photographs.
So we've got a full lasted and these are
kind of December bodied,
a genital shots just so we have nothing
to distract us.
Not a pretty phased out,
a handsome face,
et cetera.
So we've got a dangling flacid penis.
We've got an erect penis,
we've got to kind of coy,
soft porn,
female crotch shot legs together.
And then we've got a uh,
legs spread,
more hardcore shot.
So the straight women do respond to all
of it physically.
But that erect penis sends the
plethysmograph the measure of physical
response.
Sorry.
And it's just an indication,
again,
of
rawness immediacy.
And just,
uh,
kind of this is about sex.
Let's be careful before we complicate it
with all the factors that we habitually
complicate female sexuality with.
There is a core to this and we shouldn't
be so quick to look away from it.
Mm.